so Alison why do you think confidence is
on the increase yeah I mean I think we
saw a drop around the referendum time
and I think it was a lot of uncertainty
so confidence drops a little bit but
what we've seen is the economic growth
is continuing we're seeing confidence
coming back and so I think people are
getting their confidence to think about
starting businesses again so it's good
to see it's starting to come back a
little bit and all the pockets of the
country that are more entrepreneurial
than others it's reasonably well spread
I mean we have accelerator hubs right
the way across the UK and what I say is
demand for entry into those accelerators
is oversubscribed everywhere so if there
are different pockets and we definitely
see a difference between men and women's
confidence fear of failure is still the
biggest turnoff for people starting a
business that's the reason they sight or
why they don't want to start a business
and not knowing where to go for help so
the more that they can access help the
more they can access advice and support
then what helps them sort of grasp that
dream and say okay I'm going to go ahead
and do it so the stigma around failure
which previous governments and the
current one has tried to eliminate it's
still hanging around in the background I
mean most people who want to start a
business 57% of them say fear of failure
is the reason why they wouldn't so
helping people get over that fear of
failure and knowing how to get help how
to get support
what skills opportunities access to
finance access to advice that helps
mitigate that fear of failure being able
to access role models that's a really
important thing for female entrepreneurs
female role models local networks
support all of those things mitigate
that fear of failure aspects it was a
row at the time of the budget over
increased national rates for the
self-employed did that in any way do you
think impact on the desire among people
to be entrepreneurs and do you think
Hammond was right to back down I think I
mean I think it can anything that adds a
level of complexity or uncertainty or
more risk is really going to feed that
gosh am I taking a lot of risk because
for an entrepreneur starting a new
business it really is you're putting
your heart and soul into it often for a
lot of startups new entrepreneurs
they're doing it off the side of their
desk maybe alongside another job
alongside running a firm
so the more complex them will cost the
more risk those our deterrence so the
more we can mitigate those risks give
help the more likely they are to give
actually I'm going to go through it
briefly Allison you're the UK's biggest
lender to SMEs how sentiments out there
among your existing customers yeah what
I'm finding a sentiment is pretty good
although we're seeing a lot of stats
saying that business confidence has been
hit by uncertainty we're still seeing
good flow and good demand from SMEs and
small businesses and in particular what
I'm finding is businesses being very
pragmatic they're getting on with
business so we were the fastest growing
lender into the UK last year we put over
24 billion into the economy 9 billion
into commercial those trends are still
continuing so we're still seeing
confidence but uncertainty doesn't help
Alison Rose good to see you thanks for
going in thank you